[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Donnerstagabend im zweiten deutschen
Fernsehen klasse dass sie wieder mit
dabei sind die Ukraine die Ukraine
erlebt ihren ersten Kriegswinter viele
haben daran gezweifelt dass das Land so
lange standhält und nicht nur das mit
Angriffen im russischen Hinterland
scheinen die Ukraine den Spieß momentan
umzutreten Putins Armee gräbt sich
derweil ein und bombardiert weiter
ukrainische Städte die Kälte als Waffe
soll Millionen zur Fluch zwingen und
silensky offenbar an den
Verhandlungstisch dort sehen ihn
mittlerweile auch manche seiner
westlichen Verbündeten ganz gerne ist
der Zeitpunkt gekommen für Diplomatie
das fragen wir uns und diese Gäste
Alexander Graf Lamsdorf
fdp-außenpolitiker
Julian niederrümelin philosoph
die grüne Publizistin Marina Weißmann
Martin Schirdewahn Parteivorsitzender
die Linke
Nicole deitelhoff friedensforscherin und
Carlo Masala Militärexperte
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt die sind Gäste der Sendung
natürlich ausgesprochen herzlich sie
haben es alle verfolgt anscheinend ist
der Ukraine Anfang der Woche gelungen
Ziele innerhalb des russischen
Territoriums zu erreichen
es brennt am Dienstag auf dem
südrussischen Flughafen Kursk ein Öltank
steht in Flammen
mutmaßlich ein Angriff mit ukrainischen
Drohnen wie in Kursk wurden schon tags
zuvor die militärflugplätze in Engels
und jahrgilevo attackiert rund 500 km
von der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt von
hier starten Langstreckenbomber in den
Kampf drei Soldaten sollen getötet und
zwei Flugzeuge beschädigt worden sein
der US-Außenminister reagiert sofort
wir haben die Ukrainer weder ermutigt
noch befähigt innerhalb Russlands
anzugreifen
Carlo Masala ist bei uns Militärexperte
bundeswehrhochschule wenn es die Ukraine
war
dann kann sie das ohne westliche Hilfe
geschafft haben ja in der Tat kann sie
das unentwestliche Hilfe geschafft haben
wenn es Drohnen waren dann sind die aus
der Ukraine steuerbar die Frage die
interessant ist in dem Zusammenhang ist
waren ukrainische
spezialkräfteverordnung Ziele zu
markieren aber letzten Endes braucht die
Ukraine für diese Art von Aktionen und
das ist ja nicht das erste Mal ich sag
jetzt mal das im russischen Hinterland
etwas explodiert oder in Flammen aufgeht
für diese Art von Aktion braucht die
Ukraine keine Hilfe des Westens keine
direkte Hilfe ist aber
interessanterweise es sind ja
Militärflughäfen
getroffen worden also sehr explizite
militärische Ziele getroffen worden und
zwar genau und offenbar unter der
russischen Flugabwehr hindurch
sie sind sicher das ist da niemanden gab
der wieder mit Daten und mit
entsprechenden Informationen halten
Informationen die wir haben sollen sich
ja sozusagen ukrainische Spezialkräfte
vor Ort gefunden haben das ist noch
alles nicht also das ist alles nicht
bestätigt aber wenn das so ist dann sind
das diejenigen die die Ziele markieren
und die die Daten die Koordinaten weiter
an operationszentralen schicken diese
Flughäfen sind genau die Flughäfen von
denen die Langstreckenbomber hochsteigen
die die zivilen Ziele und die
Infrastruktur der Ukraine bombardieren
also von daher sozusagen Ziele wenn man
sie beschädigt und wenn man sie zerstört
die die rotieren Russen die Fähigkeit
nehmen diese Operationen gegen zivile
Ziele und Infrastruktur weiter
durchzuführen und dennoch scheint es ein
militärischer Kuh zu sein es wird
verglichen mit der Landung von Matthias
Rust auf dem Roten Platz Mann seit 87
das nur nebenbei und ich habe aber sagen
darf das Interessante ist und das war
schon bei der bei dem Angriff auf dem
Flugplatz auf der krimin der Fall
normalerweise was wir wissen ist das
sozusagen in der russischen Doktrin und
im russischen denken Flugplätze
besonders gut gesichert sind und das
scheint nicht mehr der Fall zu sein also
es ist schon sehr erstaunlich wie
nachlässig Sicherheitsvorkehrungen rund
um russische militärflug offen sind dass
solche Sachen überhaupt möglich sind bei
uns ist Nicole deidelhoff
friedensforscherin
Politikwissenschaftlerin am
Leibniz-Institut und der hessischen
Stiftung friedens- und Konfliktforschung
ist das ein gutes Recht der Ukraine sich
zu verteidigen und auch auf russischem
Territorium zu verteidigen
selbstverständlich also Russland und die
Ukraine befinden sich in einem Krieg
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen und
die Ukraine hat selbstverständlich das
Recht selbst zu Waffengewalt zu greifen
um sich zu verteidigen und es genau wie
Carlo Masala gesagt hat sie greifen hier
explizit militärische Ziele an anders
als die Russen die sich vor allen Dingen
auf zivile Ziele konzentrieren und
versuchen eben die militärischen
Angriffe sozusagen Russland dauerhaft
unterbinden also von daher ja rechtlich
gesehen gar keine Frage
selbstverständlich dürfen sie das
Alexander Graf Lambsdorff ist uns aus
Bonn zugeschaltet Graf lambsdorf diese
Drohnen können theoretisch bis Moskau
reichen haben wir nun erfahren werden
Sie zu einer Eskalation dieses Krieges
führen
ich glaube nicht dass die Ukraine die
Absicht hat die Drohnen gegen zivile
Ziele einzusetzen Frau Dr deitelhoff hat
das ja eben genau richtig gesagt es geht
ausschließlich darum
Langstreckenbomber vom 95 zu treffen das
sind genau die Langstrecken Bomber von
der aus von denen aus die Raketen auf
zivile Infrastruktur in der Ukraine
abgeschossen werden und wir wissen eines
schon seit längerem ukrainische
Spezialgruppen operieren definitiv
hinter den Linien denken wir bitte an
den Anschlag auf Alexander du gehen dem
seine Tochter zum Opfer gefallen ist das
war ganz eindeutig eine
spezialoperation der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte die war in Moskau die ging
gegen gegen einen der größten und
schlimmsten Hetzer in diesem Krieg aber
das war eine Ausnahme wirklich mit dem
was wir heute gesehen haben
wir sind in Münster verbunden mit Marina
weisterns in Kiel geboren von Bündnis 90
die Grünen wie kommt das die viel
wichtigere Frage Frau weiß man wie kommt
das bei den Menschen in der Ukraine an
was da am und Dienstag gemeldet wurde
und was vermuten sie wie kommt es in
Russland an
es ist für die Ukraine natürlich eine
ganz ganz wichtiges Signal der Hoffnung
denn die Lage am Boden sieht im Moment
sehr bedrohlich aus obwohl die Leute mit
denen ich spreche unfassbaren Mut und
Widerstandskraft und auch noch Humor
beweisen ich habe Videos bekommen aus
dunklen Supermärkten in denen die Leute
ohne Strom einkaufen in Hochhäusern wird
ohne Strom kein Wasser mehr gepumpt das
heißt es gibt kein Abwasser das heißt es
ist auch rein hygienisch eine
Katastrophe es ist kalt mitunter ne es
werden ja ganz gezielt Wärmeanlagen
gaspump-anlagen Strom Masten alles
bombardiert das heißt für die
Zivilbevölkerung ist das eine Hoffnung
hey vielleicht schaffen wir es die
russischen Angreifer so weit zu lähmen
dass sie uns nicht buchstäblich alles
unter dem Hintern wegbomben in diesem
Winter
für Russland ist es eine ganz prekäre
Situation auch für Putin ist das eine
ganz prekäre Situation in putin hatte
darauf spekuliert dass der Krieg gegen
die Ukraine erstens los wird und
zweitens ein Fernseher Ereignis denn
Fernseh kriege kommen bei der russischen
Bevölkerung traditionell sehr gut an das
steigert sein Rating jetzt allerdings
mit der massenmobilisation im frühen
Herbst und mit den Angriffen auf
russischem Boden wenn es auch
ausschließlich gegen militärische Ziele
geht kommt der Krieg tatsächlich zu den
Menschen die ihn verursachen und
anfeuern und das ist ganz gefährlich für
Putin julian niederriemelin ist bei uns
Philosoph ehemaliger Staatsminister für
Kultur mit Unterzeichner des ähm Alice
Schwarzer Briefes in diesen Krieg
tatsächlich endlich auch in einen auf
einen Weg von Verhandlungen zu bringen
wenn ich das so zusammenfassen darf wenn
die darüber liegt würden Sie sagen wir
sind in einer Situation die durchaus
eine weitere Eskalation vermuten lässt
oder ist ein Weg für Verhandlungen
geebnet also wir hatten erstmal die
merkwürdige Sondersituationen als
Weltkrieg begann beide Seiten Russland
und die Ukraine miteinander parallel
Verhandlungen geführt ohne
Waffenstillstand das kommt ja nicht alle
Tage vor und es gab auch von
ukrainischer Seite immer wieder gerade
damals von ukrainischer Seite zunächst
immer wieder die Botschaft wir sind
grundsätzlich bereit eine
verhandlungslose zu finden und jetzt
werden das Historiker später noch
genauer analysieren jedenfalls immerhin
vorhin erfährt also keine völlig
unwichtige Zeitschrift sagt es gab Ende
März Anfang April
konkrete Vereinbarungen schon zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine mit der
Zusicherung Russlands sich
zurückzuziehen also in neueroberten
Gebieten gegen Neutralität der Ukraine
Sicherheitsgarantien alles ein bisschen
nervös aber immerhin dann ist es nicht
dazu gekommen warum auch immer ja manche
sagen da hat auch der besten eine
hindernde Rolle gespielt ob das stimmt
oder nicht wird sich später
herausstellen
da gab es die Butcher grausigkeiten und
so weiter das mag auch eine wichtige
Rolle gespielt haben jedenfalls diese
Chance war dann vergeben und jetzt ist
die Frage ich bin kein Militärexperte im
Gegensatz zu ihnen und bin auch in den
Details dann nicht drin mir geht es mir
um die Perspektive wir kommen glaube ich
aus diesem Konflikt ich sage jetzt wir
die Welt insgesamt das ist ja auch ein
geopolitischer Konflikt nur raus wenn
wir auch eine Perspektive haben über die
Zeit danach wie soll das denn eigentlich
weitergehen und mir scheint die
entscheidende Punkt ist dass irgendwann
beide Seiten einsehen müssen weder Putin
kann seine Kriegsziele erreichen er hat
sie schon insofern nicht erreicht das
Regime changing Kiew nicht durchsetzbar
war die
Erwartungen dass die Bevölkerung die
russische Invasion wenigstens zu teilen
freudig begrüßt hat sich das falsche
herausgestellt im gewissen sind betreibt
Russland ein Nation building in der
Ukraine die Ukraine die in vielen Fragen
gespalten war wächst jetzt zusammen also
erstmal sind die russischen Ziele nicht
erreicht und jetzt ist die Frage kann
die Ukraine ihr Ziel was sie
legitimerweise hat nämlich alle Russen
aus ukrainischen Territorium wieder
herauszudrängen einschließlich Grimm und
den beiden Separatisten Gebieten
erreichen
wenn beide Seiten sehen unsere
Kriegsziele lassen sich nicht erreichen
oder die verteidigungsziele der Ukraine
und die Kriegsziele Russlands dann wird
es vermutlich eher die Bereitschaft
geben zu einem Waffenstillstand erstmal
zu kommen und dann geht es ja erst los
dann muss man sich überlegen wie geht
man um mit zum Beispiel den beiden
Separatisten Gebieten und der Krim da
kann man sich durchaus vorstellen ich
kann mir es vorstellen dass unter Aegide
der Vereinten Nationen echte Referenten
zum Beispiel auf der Grimm stattfinden
ja das hat im Saarland gegeben zwischen
Frankreich und Deutschland das ist
damals gut gegangen ohne Vereinte
Nationen aber es hat diese Wechsel
gegeben also ich glaube wir müssen auch
ein bisschen an die Zukunft denken wie
kommen wir aus diesem Krieg so raus dass
wir nicht eine neue
weil interessanterweise nehmen viele das
Wort Verhandlungen ausgerechnet jetzt in
den Mund umso wichtiger auch Martin
Schuld daran natürlich hat sich zu
begrüßen einer sehr Vorsitzenden der
Linken noch mal nach blinken gefragt und
nach diesen runden Angriffen gefragt
Tasche da waren warum sagt der
US-Außenminister sofort im Anschluss an
diese drei wahrscheinlich ukrainischen
Angriffe dass das von der USA weder
intendiert noch besonders unterstützt
wurde denken Sie warum macht er das das
macht aber natürlich das
Eskalationspotenzial dieses Krieges
enorm groß ist und er versucht jeden
Eindruck zu verwischen dass die
Vereinigten Staaten in irgendeiner Form
aktive Kriegspartei sind und das ist ja
nicht das erste Mal dass die Vereinigten
Staaten so reagieren das ist auch
passiert als die Flugabwehrrakete aus
der Ukraine in Polen eingeschlagen ist
und das zeigt einfach dass wir wirklich
in einer Situation sind die hochexplosiv
ist dieser Krieg ist und bleibt einfach
hochexplosiv ein Pulver fasst und die
kleinste die kleinste der kleinste
funken kann ausreichen dass dieses
Pulver fast explodiert und deswegen
machen die Vereinigten Staaten damit
natürlich stellvertreten für den Westen
deutlich gegenüber Russland dass sie an
diesen Angriffen nicht beteiligt gewesen
sind das ist auch vernünftig weil es an
dieser Stelle natürlich darum geht
tatsächlich aus einer Logik der
Eskalation heraus zu gelangen aus einer
Logik auch die immer weiter militärische
Schritte und die Eskalation in diesem
Krieg befeuert um endlich auch
tatsächlich zu einem nachhaltigen
Friedensprozess gelangen zu können das
heißt ja Verhandlung an dieser Stelle
Gespräche an dieser Stelle auf die auch
einige westliche Präsidenten oder
Staatsoberhäupter derzeit Hinweise sind
notwendig
diskutieren und vielleicht hören wir
diesen beiden des Wissens noch mal zu es
ist zum einen Job beiden und zum anderen
sein guter alter europäischer Freund
immer nur immer kommt
Verhandlungen ja sagt Joe Biden aber nur
unter klaren Bedingungen
ich bin bereit mit Mr Putin zu sprechen
wenn er sich entscheidet den Krieg
wirklich zu beenden aber das hat er
bisher nicht getan
Emmanuel macron denkt schon an die
Nachkriegsordnung und Putins sorgen
einer der Hauptpunkte die Präsident
Putin nennt ist seine Angst dass die
NATO zu nahe heranrückt und die
Stationierung von Waffen die Russland
bedrohen könnten das wird in
Friedensverhandlungen eine Rolle spielen
das ist hochinteressant Marina weißband
das ausgerechnet Emanuel macron auf die
Sicherheitsinteressen von Putin
aufmerksam macht und sie im Grunde
legitim nennt oder so darstellt wie
kommt das in ihrer Familie an
wir halten das für hochgradig naiv und
zwar naiv im besten Fall weil
Putin seit vielen Jahren mehr als
deutlich gemacht hat worum es ihm in
diesem Krieg geht nämlich um die
Zerstörung der Ukraine wenn man sagt
Putin hat legitime Sicherheitsinteressen
ignoriert man nicht nur dass die NATO
zum Zeitpunkt des Ausbruchs des Krieges
also 2014 überhaupt nichts gemacht hat
also dass dieser Krieg war keine
Reaktion auf irgendwas was die NATO
gemacht hätte sondern dieser Krieg war
eine Reaktion auf den Euro da man
ignoriert die russische imperialistische
Logik aus russische imperialistischer
Sicht ist die Ukraine eine abtrünnige
Provinz und Russland muss beweisen das
ist die Ukraine ohne Russland nicht
geben kann und das ist in der Lage ist
die Ukraine zu zerstören nur wenn es
diese beiden Punkte beweisen kann
riskiert es nicht das weitere Teile von
diesem Imperium abdrücken und das ist
Putins größte Angst er schreibt es ganz
deutlich er hat es in diesem Sommer
Aufsatz geschrieben letztes Jahr
er hat es er wiederholt es jeden Abend
im russischen Fernsehen seine
Propagandisten wiederholen jeden Abend
im russischen Fernsehen es gibt kein
solches Volk der Ukraine die Ukraine
darf es auf der Landkarte nicht geben
wie naiv muss man jetzt als
Regierungschef sein und zu sagen es geht
ihm irgendwie um die Nato und um
Sicherheitsinteressen das ist sehr
offensichtlich vorgeschoben und es
ignoriert seine vollkommen klar
artikuliert Absichtserklärung die
Ukraine auszulöschen warum noch mal die
Frage warum macht Emanuel macron das was
ist dessen Interesse dahinter oder kann
es jemanden geben der ihn dazu bringt
oder zwingt
es kann natürlich sein ich habe kein
Geheimdienst das kann natürlich sein das
Putin Dreck gegen ihn hat die einfachere
Erklärung ist dass er in einer
geopolitischen dass er in einer
geopolitischen denk einfach ist in der
es immer noch der Kalte Krieg eine Rolle
spielt in der diese Versöhnung mit
Russland eine Rolle spielt und in der er
sich in dieser französischen Tradition
sieht immer diesen Draht zum äh zu
Russland zu halten interessant waren sie
haben das gilt es unbedingt zu erwähnen
sechs Ukraine aufgenommen eine
ukrainische Familie wie reagieren die
darauf wie reagieren die darauf dass der
US-amerikanische Präsident und noch viel
deutlicher nicht zum ersten Mal muss man
sagen immer Manuel macron sich um
Vladimir Putin sorgt und um dessen
Unterstützung ja ich hatte eine Familie
aufgenommen in der Tat die vor dem
Kriegsgeschehen geflüchtet ist in der
sechsköpfige Familie und habe dieser
Familie geholfen Fuß zu fassen in ihrem
neuen Leben im neuen Land sozusagen die
reagieren natürlich
hochsensibel auf all das was in der
Ukraine geschieht die sind erst von der
Krim geflohen nach Nikolaev was jetzt
auch immer noch in der Nähe unmittelbar
Nähe der Front sich befindet sind dann
von dort weiter geflohen und sind
mittlerweile aber gut in ihrem neuen
Leben angekommen das freut mich sehr das
war natürlich
wie gesagt die reagieren hochsensibel
darauf Teile der eigenen Familie sind
dort auch im Kampf sozusagen ich will
jetzt auch nicht weiter darauf eingehen
geht das alles natürlich total nah aber
trotzdem ist ja das Ziel was man
verfolgt ich finde nicht naiv an dieser
Stelle sondern ganz im Gegenteil hat ja
auch angekündigt dass er im Januar nach
China fahren will nach besing und dort
mit HI zu verhandeln und China erscheint
ja im Moment auch die einzige wirkliche
Macht zu sein die noch politischen
Einfluss auf Russland hat und an dieser
Stelle auch auf Putin um Putin zu
bewegen diesen elenden Krieg endlich zu
beenden und ich halte das für einen sehr
klugen Schachzug von macron an dieser
Stelle nach China fahren zu wollen und
gleichzeitig auch eine Perspektive
aufzumachen für eine europäische
Friedensordnung nach diesem Krieg weil
dieser Krieg irgendwann zu Ende gehen
wird und wir müssen uns die Frage
stellen wie dann das Zusammenleben der
Nationen und der Völker in diesem Europa
das unseres ist sozusagen auch
funktionieren kann
wir werden über diese
Sicherheitsinteressen reden weil
natürlich hat auch die Ukraine
berechtigte Sicherheitsinteressen
genauso wie andere Länder Europas auch
und die gilt es zu schützen da gibt es
eine interessante Äußerung von Olaf
Scholz aber bleiben wir noch mal eine
Sekunde beim Sinn von Verhandlungen
jetzt
graslandsdorf normalerweise sagt man die
haben keinen Sinn wenn beide Seiten auf
maximalpositionen
oder sagte Diplomat eigentlich dass
immer Verhandlungen bei
Maximalforderungen beginnen
das stimmt Verhandlungen beginnen
üblicherweise bei Maximalforderungen
aber ich glaube das ist zurzeit wenn es
denn um Verhandlungen ginge ja um
Verhandlungen ginge ohne Beteiligung der
Ukraine die Ukraine ist zurzeit nicht
bereit für Verhandlungen und wir können
ja als Westen nicht den Menschen in Kiew
sagen der Regierung dort passt mal auf
wir verhandeln jetzt mal mit dem Putin
wir sagen euch dann was dabei
herausgekommen ist und die Ergebnisse
habt ihr dann zu akzeptieren so kann es
natürlich überhaupt nicht funktionieren
sondern das ganze wird nur funktionieren
wenn die Ukraine und da hat er nie
darüber reden überlegen das eben genau
richtig gesagt selber genau wie die
Russen der Meinung ist militärisch geht
nichts mehr dann kann man verhandeln an
welchem Punkt das ist muss die Ukraine
entscheiden und das Ziel der Verhandlung
und darum geht es dann müssen gerechte
Frieden sein und das muss ein
dauerhafter Frieden sein und zu einem
dauerhaften Frieden gehört dass Russland
sich endlich darüber klar wird was für
ein Verhältnis ist zu Europa haben
möchte will es wirklich dieses
aggressive in revisionistische Deo
imperialistische
Auftreten an den Tag legen auch in
Zukunft dann wird dieses Verhältnis ein
kalter friedenswert aber das kann es ja
nicht sein und deswegen glaube ich die
Hoffnung auf Verhandlungen zur Zeit
sollte man nicht zu hoch hängen sondern
wir müssen Russland an einem Punkt
angekommen ist wo sich über seine eigene
Zukunft in Europa klar geworden ist oder
aber über seine Zukunft an der Seite
Chinas als abhängiger Vasallenstaat ich
glaube nicht dass das im Interesse
Russland ist Ulrike deitelhoff denn
Marina weißband Frau deitelhoff wenn Joe
beiden sich jetzt dennoch zu einem
Gespräch anbietet wohl wissend unter
genau dieser Kondition Putin muss bereit
sein den Krieg zu beenden aber ich biete
mich zum Gespräch an warum ist das in
ihren Augen trotzdem eine gute Nachricht
die gute Nachricht daran ist dass bei
beiden hier mit eigentlich was
signalisieren will er will signalisieren
die Tür ist nicht vollkommen zu wenn du
bereit bist umzukehren wenn du bereit
bist in die Regeln und Praktiken unsere
Ordnung zurückzukehren dann werde ich
sogar mit entsprechend dazu muss man
einfach wissen also Putin hat ja nicht
die ganze Zeit nur über ein
neoimperiales Reich gesprochen er hat
auch die ganze Zeit über Raketen
Bedrohung gesprochen er hat über die
Frage gesprochen ob eigentlich Russland
noch so behandelt wird wie es sich
gehört und einer der Punkte war immer
dass er eigentlich nie mit der Ukraine
und auch nicht mit Europa verhandeln
wollte er wollte mit den USA verhandeln
das ist sozusagen aus seiner Sicht der
legitime Ansprechpartner für ihn und das
beiden jetzt signalisiert pass auf wenn
du bereit bist wirklich umzukehren wenn
du ernst machen willst dann bin ich auch
bereit dir diese Gelegenheit zu geben
gesprächig tatsächlich mit dir auf
Augenhöhe das ist sozusagen gutes Signal
denn man muss sich klar machen sowohl
sie Lenski also auch Putin haben
unglaublich wenig manövriert Spielraum
beide haben sich so weit aus dem Fenster
lehnen müssen um auch zu mobilisieren
dass sie sozusagen in ihrem jeweiligen
Ländern dass sie eigentlich kaum noch
groß zurück warten können und das heißt
diese Signale die jetzt eben auch beiden
gibt sind ganz wichtig um überhaupt so
ein bisschen Zuversicht zu schaffen es
gibt noch Wege es gibt noch
Möglichkeiten daraus noch mal Marina mit
einer Frage vorneweg Frau weißbein
blinken hat auch davor gewarnt dass es
einen Scheinfrieden mit Moskau geben
könnte also Anthony blinken hat nicht
nur gesagt wir haben das hier nicht
unterstützt er hat auch gesagt seine
größte Sorge ist die vor einem
Scheinfrieden das Putin pro forma einen
Friedensschluss sucht um eigentlich Zeit
zu gewinnen ist das auch ihre größte
absolut ich habe lustigerweise vor ein
paar Wochen bei Anne Will gesagt oder
Anfang des Herbstes dass wir Anfang des
Winters darüber reden werden ob es
Verhandlungen geben kann weil das
entweder von macron oder von Scholz
angestoßen wird und das ist genauso
gekommen und das ist keine Überraschung
aber was dahinter steckt ist natürlich
das Russland jetzt wo die Ukraine
tatsächlich massiv Gewinne macht und der
Winter steht bevor wir haben eine
russische Armee ohne Winterausrüstung
ohne adäquate natürlich braucht er jetzt
ein Waffenstillstand und natürlich wirft
Putin jetzt seinen Kontakten sozusagen
hin hey wir können doch jetzt mal über
den Waffenstillstand reden dahinter
steckt ja aber gar nicht das Ziel ein
Frieden zu erreichen da wäre ich ja als
erste mit dabei um Gottes Willen hey
meine Familie wird nicht bombardiert
cool unbedingt aber das Problem ist es
läuft ja nicht auf einen Frieden hinaus
sondern es läuft darauf hinaus jetzt das
ukraineische Vorrücken zu bremsen den
Winter über Putin die Zeit zu geben
aufzurüsten nachzurüsten aus dem Iran
die neuen Drohnen zu bestellen übrigens
ein groß an alle iranischen Frauen die
kämpfen weil die tatsächlich eine große
Rolle in diesem Krieg spielen aber
danach wird er ja unweigerlich natürlich
die Ukraine wieder angreifen und das
wissen wir historisch von weiter
zurückliegenden Beispielen was wiesnend
bringt gegen jemanden der eine absolut
imperiale Absicht erklärt wir wissen das
aber auch von Putin selbst denn dieser
Krieg wurde ja schon eingefroren 2015
das können wir jetzt noch paar Mal
wiederholen das wird sich aber in immer
größerer Skala wiederholen und ich
möchte echten Frieden und echten Frieden
erreichen wir durch echte Verhandlungen
und echte Sachen erreichen wir dann wenn
wir Fakten geschaffen haben die Putin
zwingen sich an sein Wort sollen wir
sind Herr Masala bei der Frage ist das
in ihren Augen jetzt auch ein guter
Zeitpunkt diplomatisch diese Türen zu
öffnen oder sagen Sie im Grunde ist die
Gefahr viel größer dass nur einer
wirklich Zeit braucht und der heißt
Vladimir Putin
also Putin braucht eindeutig eine
taktische Pause ihr braucht eindeutig
eine taktische Pause um sozusagen seine
Probleme im Osten und dem Süden aus
seiner Sicht zu lösen das heißt die
timemobilisierten heranzuführen wir
hören sozusagen dass in
Munitionsfabriken in Russland
Doppelschichten gefahren werden es gibt
Berichte unbestätigte Art das sozusagen
alte T50 hinter dem oral rausgeholt
werden aus dem Depots Putin hat heute
eine Rede gehalten oder gestern in der
gesagt hat es könnte ein sehr langer
Konflikt werden also von daher sozusagen
auf der rhetorischen Ebene auf der
materiellen Ebene bereitet sich Russland
für eine lange militärische
Auseinandersetzung vor aber es braucht
halt Zeit um die entsprechenden
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen und da kommt
eine taktische Pause gelegen ich will
einen Punkt sagen zu dem was Herr Graf
Lamsdorf gesagt hat weil ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig natürlich fangen
Verhandlungen mit Maximalforderungen an
wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen
russlandschaft Fakten Russland
integriert vier Oblaste in seinen
Staatsterritorium und diese Oblaste wird
es laut russischer Verfassung nur extrem
schwer wieder aus dem Staatsterritorium
entlassen können das heißt also Russland
geht nicht nur mit Maximalforderungen
rein sondern russlandschaft Fakten die
de facto es für silenski unmöglich
machen sich auf Verhandlungen
einzulassen weil sie nur darauf
hinauslaufen können dass er Gebiete
verliert und ich glaube selenski würde
das politisch nicht überleben in der
Ukraine wenn da ein Staat seit 9 Monaten
sozusagen Krieg führt also ich finde das
sozusagen relativ wichtig zu beiden hat
sehr deutlich gesagt er ist bereit zu
verhandeln was völlig in Ordnung ist
meines Erachtens zum ersten Mal ja aber
er sagt wenn Russland mit seinen Truppen
raus aus der Ukraine ist also es ist
nicht einfach so wir verhandeln jetzt
wenn Putin sagt lass uns einen Tisch
kommen sondern er sagt die Voraussetzung
ist Russland verlässt inklusive Grimm
die Ukraine dann können wir verhandeln
mit Blick auf die Sicherheitsinteressen
also erstens zwei Sachen erstens finde
ich es immer interessant dass wir alle
jetzt auch mit Blick auf die
Drohnenangriffe wir haben alle Angst vor
der Eskalation in diesem Konflikt und da
frage ich mich die ganze Zeit der
einzige der eskaliert in diesem
Konfliktes Russland also russland hat in
den letzten Tagen 400 Raketen auf die
Ukraine abgefeuert legt dieses Land in
Schutt und Asche aber wir haben Angst
sozusagen vor einer Eskalation durch die
Russische Föderation das ist ein
bisschen paradox weil sozusagen da
stehen wir dann irgendwie mit unserer
Angst auf der falschen Seite also wir
sollten sozusagen eher die Angst haben
wie weit Russland in der Ukraine noch
eskalieren kann um dieses Land in
Trümmern zu legen und bei den
Sicherheitsinteressen wenn es nur wenn
es wirklich um die Neutralität der
Ukraine geht wenn es wirklich um die
Frage der NATO geht wenn es wirklich um
die Frage von Stationierung von
Mittelstrecken Raketen geht das hätte
Putin vor dem 24 februar haben können
das haben ihm alle zugesichert
das hätte Putin haben können als
verhandelt worden ist in Istanbul
und seit dem 24 Februar spielt die
nato-argumentation in der russischen
Argumentation warum sie Krieg führen
eigentlich fast keine Rolle mehr und
jetzt kommen macron um die Ecke und
zieht das wieder hoch und legitimiert
damit letzten Endes ein falsches
narrativ das Russland benutzt hat um ein
Angriffskrieg zu führen das hinterlässt
mich alles ein bisschen sprachlos ja das
haben sie jetzt freundlich formuliert ja
das NATO narrativ das ist Professor
Masala gerade gesagt hat das ganz
interessant weil es eine janusköpfige
Geschichte ist nach außen ist es genauso
wie Herr Masala sagt nach außen wird es
natronarativ gar nicht so sehr benutzt
aber nach innen in den ganzen
Fernsehsendung wenn Sie Margarita Simon
Jan zu hören beispielsweise ja ich sagte
gar kein Krieg gegen Kiel wir führen
Krieg gegen London und Paris und Berlin
also das natronarativ ist immer russisch
ein enorm starkes und diese Ansage dass
das ganze ein langer Krieg werden könnte
hat glaube ich auch was damit zu tun
dass er die Bevölkerung darauf ein
schwören will eben in diesen Krieg diese
Maximalposition dazu gehört für mich
auch beispielsweise diese Annektion mit
dem innerrussischen Rechtsfolgen die das
dann zeitigt dass er die russische
Bevölkerung einstellen will eben mit der
NATO oder in Gespräche zu gehen und
deswegen ist richtig was sie gesagt
worden ist Joe Biden als
Gesprächspartner ist für ihn der
interessanteste von allen das macronder
gesagt hat das ist wirklich hochgradig
unklug weil er im Grunde auf ein
innerrussisches narrativ anspringt das
völlig überflüssig ist und das hätte
macron einfach nicht tun dürfen das
hätte er nicht tun dürfen sagt Graf
lamster Frau deitelhoff hälts kaum noch
auf dem Stuhl wie sieht das anders ich
möchte vielleicht einen Punkt dazu
machen ich ich stimme vollkommen zu dass
das erstens eine innere russische
Debatte vor allen Dingen ist und ich
würde zweitens auch sagen dass diese
Sicherheitsinteressen und die ist da
geht nicht wirklich berechtigt sind also
wenn man sich das einfach mal anguckt
dann müssen wir auch bei den
Mittelstrecken Raketen sagen das vor
allen Dingen Russland hier im Fokus
steht in Russland hat mit den Strecken
Raketen sozusagen entwickelt ja und die
NATO nicht die Nato hat ein Raketen ab
dieses System entwickelt und dagegen
sozusagen wendet sich Russland ja aber
das ist letzten Endes egal es ist egal
ob das sozusagen berechtigt ist oder
nicht wenn das ein ganz zentrales
Argument ist dann lohnt es sich
tatsächlich dass zum Thema zu machen
also zum Beispiel anzubieten meine Güte
dann reden wir eben tatsächlich darüber
was eigentlich Stabilisierung für dich
bedeutet was meint man denn in Russland
wenn man über Stabilisierung spielt kann
man sagen das haben wir doch alles vor
dem 24 Februar schon gemacht ich würde
sagen das stimmt aber in der Diplomatie
ist es tatsächlich so dass man die
gleiche Sache hunderte Male macht bis
sie einmal verfängt also es lohnt sich
nicht zu sagen das ist alles ohnehin
nur vorgeschoben deswegen machen wir das
nicht wieder sondern tatsächlich
Diplomatie basiert darauf das müssen 100
erstes 110 ist und dann vielleicht
das Zeichen dass Joe Biden der neuerlich
gibt zum anderen auch ausdrückt das auf
anderen unteren Ebenen längst geredet
wird darüber reden wir hier auch nicht
zum ersten Mal gibt es denn schon
irgendetwas was sie wissen und profund
wissen was man sich gegenseitig anbieten
könnte außer den Punkt den Sie gerade
selbst nennen also ich glaube es ist
tatsächlich
also könnte es sein dass diese vier
annektierten Gebiete von Putin verwandt
werden oder aber auch von der anderen
Seite verwandt werden in irgendeiner
Form weil er sie vielleicht wirklich
nicht halten kann also tatsächlich habe
ich am Anfang sehr darauf gehofft dass
diese Strategie diese vier Oblaste zu
annektieren wohl wissen dass kein Staat
das würde akzeptieren dass das
tatsächlich ein Versuch war den
verhandlungskuchen erstmal zu vergrößern
um dann etwas in Verhandlung hergeben zu
können wenn ich mir aber anschaue wie es
seitdem läuft dann muss man wirklich
sagen dass er keinerlei Flexibilität
mehr zeigt und das ist übrigens auch
etwas zu dieser Finte und der will nur
eine taktische Pause wenn er das
wirklich nur wollen würde nur die
taktische Pause dann wäre er ja so klug
und würde tatsächlich erste Bewegung
machen und sagen na ja wir können auch
noch mal über die vier Oblast sprechen
nur das macht er überhaupt nicht er hat
auf beiden reagiert und hat gesagt alles
schön und nett aber so lange Bein oder
Pesto hat das natürlich gesagt so lange
beiden nicht die neuen Gebiete Russlands
anerkennt brauchen wir hier gar nicht
weiter reden und das heißt er hat ja gar
keine Zugeständnisse gemacht insofern
muss man wirklich sagen ich hatte
gehofft das wäre eine Strategie den
verhandlungskuchen zu vergrößern aber so
sieht es nicht aus so hat es sich nicht
entwickelt und jetzt haben sich beide
eher eingemauert und können auch ob der
Dinge die sie ihren Bevölkerungen
erzählen wenn sich das überhaupt
vergleichen lässt natürlich sehr sehr
schwer von diesen Positionen wieder
zurück den Bundeskanzler hatte ich
angekündigt der eine macron äußert sich
zu den Sicherheitsinteressen der Russen
und Olaf Scholz äußerte sich zu den
Sicherheitsinteressen der Ukraine
in Abstimmung mit unseren Partnern steht
Deutschland bereit nach dem Krieg
Vereinbarungen zu treffen mit denen die
Sicherheit der Ukraine wird
wie könnten diese Sicherheitsinteressen
Aussehen ganz konkret und welchen
Beitrag könnte tatsächlich auch in
historischen vergleichen Deutschland da
leisten ja ich glaube das ist genau der
Punkt also das ist jedenfalls die
Botschaft die ich gerne jetzt hier in
dieser Debatte auch unterbringen würde
wir sind sehr fokussiert auf diesen
Konflikt verständlicherweise es ist ja
schrecklich was alles passiert und wie
viele Menschen sterben
aber Henry kissenscher sagt nicht ganz
zu Unrecht wir stehen am Rande eines
Krieges
mit China so hat er sich im September
ausgedrückt mit China und Russland
an issues also an Fragen oder Themen an
denen wir selbst unseren Anteil haben
und es ist nicht klar was wir eigentlich
für Ziele verfolgen wie wir daraus
kommen sollen also ich mache jetzt mal
ganz große Bild drei großmächtige drei
Supermächte die mit dem Status Quo nicht
zufrieden sind China schafft
Abhängigkeiten asymmetrische Verträge
Seidenstraße aber auch in Afrika und
anderswo rüstet massiv auf
die USA hat 800 Militärstützpunkte
weltweit sie hat ihre
Einflussmöglichkeiten wesentlich
erweitert in den letzten Jahrzehnten und
Russland versucht im Grunde den Alter
imperialer Geste wieder ein Art russisch
geführtes Reich zu etablieren mit
Abhängigkeiten sezessionsbewegungen
unterstützen und so weiter ohne eine
große wirtschaftliche Kraft mal gesagt
wollte mit Atomwaffen
hat aber es ist richtig also der ist
Bruttoinlandprodukt pro Kopf in Russland
ist ungefähr gleich hoch wie in China
china hat zehn Mal so viel Einwohner als
Russland also entsprechend kann man sich
das Ausrechnen also die Frage ist wie
schaffen wir Stabilität wieder in dieser
Welt und da war ich auch vorher nicht so
ganz unzufrieden bei allem Respekt Frau
weißband ich meine wir hatten vielleicht
ist auch ein bisschen
Generationenkonflikt ja die Erfahrung
des Kalten Krieges war ja die Vorsicht
wir müssen Stabilität
bewahren und das war die große Lehre der
Kubakrise Kuba waren souveräner Staat
wollte
mittelstreckenwaffen Russlands nuklear
bestückt stationieren hat sie auch schon
stationiert und da stand an der Grenze
des dritten weltkrieges
wenn man das mal genau anschaut wie das
jetzt auch rekonstruiert worden ist und
dann wurde daraus der Schluss gezogen
okay Stabilität muss auf jeden Fall
angestrebt werden und Stabilität heißt
natürlich auch dass man
Sicherheitsinteressen oder auch nur
wahrgenommene Sicherheitsinteressen der
anderen Seite vielleicht irren sie sich
ja und es ist ganz anders ja dass man
die ernst nimmt und deswegen glaube ich
dass wir dringend jetzt nicht in erster
Linie ein Gespräch darüber führen
sollten was alles vielleicht dagegen
spreche jetzt ein Waffenstillstand zu
erreichen das ist im Augenblick
wahrscheinlich völlig unrealistisch
sondern zu überlegen wie können wir denn
eine Struktur anstreben bei der wir zum
Beispiel konventionellen strukturelle
nicht angriffsfähigkeit in Europa ein
Ziel was intensiv diskutiert wurde
herstellen also was passieren kann wenn
ein Staat eben nicht angriffsfähig
gemacht werden soll dieses Schicksal hat
die Ukraine wenn Sie so wollen ja hart
erlitten weil es hat ja in diesen
Verhandlungen Ende der 90er Jahre seine
Atomwaffen hergegeben weil es auf diese
Sicherheiten baut man noch was anderes
das ist das Positive es ist nicht das
eingetreten was auch die deutschen
Geheimdienste prognostiziert haben die
Ukraine ist nicht zusammengebrochen
innerhalb weniger Tage sondern es ist
bis heute eine kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung mit Verlusten von
jetzt glaube ich 18% des Territorium der
Unterstützung und Hilfe gerade genau das
heißt also es ist möglich strukturelle
nicht angriffsfähigkeit unter bestimmten
Bedingungen zu etablieren wir brauchen
auch wir haben Verhandlungen geführt
Behandlung darf ich das sagen wir haben
Verhandlungen geführt in einer Zeit also
70er Jahre da war die Sowjetunion ein
übler spätsteinistischer Staat mit dem
bulax-system Nixen hat Anfang der 70er
Jahre mit ping pong Diplomatie Tina
begonnen Gespräche zu führen und
Kooperationen aufzubauen mit Mao der für
20 Millionen Tote in der
Kulturrevolution verantwortlich war und
deswegen sage ich wir dürfen jetzt nicht
so tun als wäre für alle Zeit jede
Streben nach einer stabilen Weltordnung
unter Einbeziehung auch sehr
problematischer Akteure unmöglich wenn
man das tun
dennoch Marina
ich wollte einfach antworten da ich
direkt angesprochen wurde
erstens es wurde keine nicht
Angreifbarkeit von der Ukraine etabliert
die Ukraine hat Sicherheitsgarantien
bekommen und die wurden gebrochen und
die Ukraine wehrt sich nicht nur dank
der Hilfe des Westens sondern in den
ersten Wochen in den ersten Tagen war
sie auf sich allein gestellt und hat den
besten einfach nur dadurch überrascht
wie gut sie sich gewehrt hat und hätte
sie das nicht geschafft dann hätte sich
auch niemand um Hilfe bemüht die Ukraine
wird gerade angegriffen die Ukraine wird
gerade zerbomben es finden gerade
Massenmorde statt es findet gerade
und das klein zu reden mit naja das ist
ja irgendwie äh da ist es ja irgendwas
gelungen meine ist überhaupt nichts
gelungen das ist eine Katastrophe die
Ukraine ist auch keine Verhandlungsmasse
sie ist ein souveräner Staat ich möchte
aber mit Ihnen zusammen gehen und sagen
okay lassen Sie uns diese stabile
Weltordnung bauen Stabilität beginnt in
meinem Verständnis damit das nicht
einfach ein Staat hingehen kann und die
Grenzen eines anderen staatsgewaltsam
verschieben kann
wenn wir uns darauf einigen das bedeutet
doch eine Politik der Stabilität würde
jede Form so eine Aggression so
massieren
absolut undenkbar wäre für andere
Staaten wenn wir jetzt ein Frieden mit
Putin machen wenn wir ihm jetzt
irgendwas geben irgendein Territorium
dann ist doch das nächste was passiert
dass China Taiwan angreift weil
plötzlich ist es absolut legitim in den
Augen der Weltgemeinschaft
leiden wenn wir Stabilität wollen dann
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass ein
Aggressor bestraft wird und nichts
gewinnt aus einer Aggression
wir sind Carlo Masala noch mal bei der
Frage was Olaf Scholz meinen könnte wenn
er sagt wir die deutschen er formuliert
eine Aufgabe für die Deutschen werden
die Sicherheitsinteressen der Ukraine
mit verteidigen helfen wie kann das
aussehen ich glaube dieser Satz ist in
die Richtung zu interpretieren in die
Olaf Scholz schon mehrfach argumentiert
hat das sozusagen Deutschland nach
diesem Krieg sehr führend daran
beteiligt wird diese ukrainische Armee
vor allen Dingen im Bereich der Luft
Verteidigung und ich weiß jetzt nicht
noch in welchen anderen Bereichen
auszustatten und auszurüsten also
Deutschland als Staat selber kann der
Ukraine keine Sicherheitsgarantien im
Sinne von harten militärischen
Sicherheitsgarantien geben weil das
Gegenüber dass die Ukraine nochmals
überfallen könnte halt eine nuklear
macht ist und da sind deutsche
Sicherheitsgarantien ganz einfach zu
schwach ich glaube es ist eher da
hingehen zu verstehen dass sich
Deutschland darum bemühen wird
sei es vielleicht sozusagen in
Verhandlungen
entmilitarisierte Zonen zu schaffen die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte so auszurüsten
dass sie in bestimmten Bereichen
sozusagen vor russischen
Raketenangriffen noch besser geschützt
sind als sie es jetzt ohnehin sind aber
es geht nicht darum dass die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland jetzt sagt in
dem Fall wenn die Ukraine verteidigt
angegriffen wird werden wir zur
Verteidigung der Ukraine herbeeilen weil
es bringt nichts das schreckt keinen ab
weil wir sind keine nuklear macht werden
auch nie eine werden und auf der anderen
Seite ist der einzige Kreis sondern
nuklearme es gibt aber ganz kurz was ich
finde diese historische Analogie sehr
sehr problematisch weil erstens spricht
sich keiner gegen Stabilität aus
Stabilität wird sich einstellen in dem
Moment in dem es eine stabile sozusagen
Balance im internationalen System geben
wird das ist aber ein Prozess der
langfristig ist und ich glaube der ganz
wichtige Unterschied ist gegenwärtig
wenn sie auf die 70er Jahre reagieren
in Europa wir reden jetzt nur in Europa
nicht in anderen Teilen der Welt aber
die Sowjetunion meine Status Quo macht
die wollte sozusagen das was sie haben
Zweiten Weltkrieg gewonnen und gesichert
hat wollte sie gesichert sehen sie
wollte es anerkannt wissen also die
große Leistung von Henry Kissinger war
einfach zu sagen wir behandeln die jetzt
als Großmacht und in Helsinki machen wir
den Deal Unverletzlichkeit der Grenzen
das heißt für die Sowjetunion euer
Einflussgebiet ist sicher dafür kriegen
wir halt alle anderen Sachen im Bereich
sozusagen humanitären und Menschenrechte
wir haben es bei Russland mit einer
revanchistischen Macht zu tun und das
ist der große Unterschied die haben kein
Interesse am Status quo die haben ein
Interesse sozusagen den Status Quo über
den Haufen zu werfen politisch
ökonomisch und militärisch und deshalb
finde ich diese historische Analogie ein
bisschen problematisch sprich von drei
revisionistischen Supermächten
eine revisionistische macht weil sie das
System so verändern wollten dass sie für
alle Zeit
Nummer 1 sind ich sehe sozusagen weder
unter Obama also selbst unter Trump und
jetzt unter beiden sehe ich den
Revisionismus nicht ich rede nicht von
jetzt von den letzten Jahren so ich rede
von einer Destabilisierung der
weltverhältnisse die damit zusammenhängt
dass wir genau diese Lehre aus dem
Kalten Krieg nämlich behutsam zwischen
nuklear Mächten umzugehen in den Wind
geschrieben haben es gab es gab zum
Beispiel
2007/2008 ich weiß nicht ob sie das
anders sehen da war die Ukraine
vermutlich von Seiten Russlands nicht
gefährdet war nicht gefährdet es gab den
Angebot von Georgia Bush die Ukraine und
Georgien in die NATO aufzunehmen in dem
Moment ändern sich endgültig die
nato-osterweitung ist ja wenn auch
zähneknirschend aber im Großen und
Ganzen akzeptiert worden
haben das verhindern
aber das nenne ich revisionistisch warum
war denn das erforderlich diese dieses
Angebot überhaupt noch zu machen aber
das ist doch Alter Kaffee wir sind jetzt
bei 2,2 verstehen wie solche Konflikte
zustande kommen und eine Perspektive für
die Zukunft zu entwickeln da kann man
nicht immer nur die letzten drei Jahre
betrachten kann man nicht aber man kann
auch nicht einzelne Ereignisse
herausgreifen und denken dass ich an
denen die komplette Zukunft
noch viel genauer schildern ja aber
insgesamt haben wir eine
Destabilisierung der internationalen
Ordnung dass Sie zustimmen und wir
müssen uns überlegen wie kommt man
wieder zu einer stabilen Ordnung zurück
das ist nicht nur Russland das ist China
auch ja das ist die USA auch in ihrer
Weise wir haben diese ganzen regime
change Aktivitäten mit wenig Erfolg mit
praktiziert auch um Einflusszonen
aufzubauen den Irak als ein Brückenkopf
in dieser Region zu etablieren und so
weiter das war aber ebenfalls ein
völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskriegskrise oder überhaupt
Völkerrecht Verletzung lassen sich nicht
gegeneinander aufrechnen also die einen
machen die anderen ja nicht besser nein
aber
genauso wie die anderen sein und das ist
nicht wahr all das was sie sagen ist
richtig nur in meiner Analyse hat das
die Position der USA so geschwächt dass
sie Russische Föderation und China darin
die Chance sehen sozusagen dieses System
das von den USA getragen wird jetzt
endlich von uns vom Kopf auf die Füße zu
stellen
ja mit den Fehlern die begangen wurden
aber der Schluss ist die USA haben sich
im Prinzip mit uns Europäern selber ins
Knie geschossen weil sie sich relativ so
geschwächt haben und unglaubwürdig
geworden sind das ist für die
revisionistischen Mächte die Möglichkeit
gab jetzt diese Liberalen
Anführungszeichen Weltordnung
Endgültigkeit genau
das alte Spiel das sozusagen wir alles
bestimmen können das ist aus ja genau
das Problem ist tatsächlich diese
Politik ja auch fortgesetzt wird wenn
man sich das Beispiel der Türkei ansieht
als NATO Mitglied das gerade in wäre
jetzt wieder den Angriffskrieg im Irak
und in Syrien gegen die Kurde und Kurden
führt das heißt ja da gibt es keine
Veränderung tatsächlich sondern eine
fortgesetzte Destabilisierung auch in
dieser Region durch eine Macht die
Deutschland ja auch als Alliierten
betrachtet oder dann eben ein
NATO-Mitglied natürlich auch ein Partner
ist an dieser Stelle aber das er
tatsächlich dadurch andere Kräfte sich
ermächtigt und ermutigt fühlen eben
genau in dieser Auseinandersetzung zu
gehen und sich ein Beispiel daran zu
nehmen und dann eben gewaltsam Grenzen
zu verschieben wie wir es jetzt im Falle
des Völkerrechts wenig Angriffskrieges
Russland gegen die Ukraine erleben die
Frage trotzdem muss ja legitim bleiben
erstens wir wieder ein Völkerrecht
etablieren dass wir alle verbindlich ist
an dieser Stelle weil es gibt ja ein
Völkerrecht natürlich sind diese Kriege
alle völkerrechtswidrig allesamt und
gleichzeitig muss man auch darüber
nachdenken wie man eine Friedensordnung
schafft sich der Konflikte Bewusstsein
das ist an dieser Stelle zum Beispiel
natürlich im Süd chinesische Meer und im
indupazifik weitere Spannung geben wird
weil diese Gefahren zwischen den
Vereinigten Staaten und China eher
zunimmt als abnimmt im Moment und
Russland natürlich im Schatten auch
dieses Konfliktes versucht die Grenzen
neu zu ziehen ich finde trotzdem gut
dass wir in einem Punkt angelangt sind
wo wir über Sicherheitsinteressen auch
in diesem Konflikt reden
waren welche sind denn legitime
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
formulieren Sie das genau wie Herr
macron oder sogar noch anders und
welches sind legitime
Sicherheitsinteressen der Ukraine und
wie würden Sie denken dass wir die
schützen können letztendlich finde ich
den Fortschritt erstmal dass wir
tatsächlich also der Bundeskanzler die
ukrainischen Sicherheitsinteressen
erwähnt immer Frauen die russischen
Sicherheitsinteresse natürlich haben
diese beiden Länder Sicherheit
Interessen auch wenn Sie sich jetzt
gerade in einem Kriegszustand
miteinander befinden natürlich muss man
auch darüber nachdenken wie diese
Sicherheits Interessen miteinander in
Einklang gebracht werden damit man ein
dauerhaften Frieden zwischen diesen
beiden Länder findet für mich ist klar
dass Russland sich aus der Ukraine
zurückziehen musste das ist eindeutig an
dieser Stelle aber trotzdem muss man
jetzt neutrales Gebiet also wie muss man
sich das vorstellen dann wird die
Ukraine
zentraler Staat ich möchte den ich
möchte den verhandelnden ja nicht
vorschreiben wie letztendlich sie ihre
Sicherheitsinteressen zu definieren
haben aber offensichtlich liegt die
Ukraine Wert darauf dass sie
Sicherheitsgarantien auch aus dem Westen
erhält an dieser Stelle das ist
sicherlich ein gangbarer Weg über den
man an dieser Stelle dann auch
nachdenken muss aber Hauptsache es kommt
zu einer Situation wo die Region wieder
stabil wird und da ist notwendig dass
man jetzt akzeptiert dass beide Länder
Sicherheitsinteressen haben und es ist
auch notwendig dass man jetzt schon das
Ende also
worin bestehen ich frag's noch mal
legitime Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
können Sie das beantworten weil wir
haben es ja mit einem Aggressor zu tun
man will einen Aggressor stoppen man
sollte nicht nur den Krieg stoppen
wollen sollte doch einen ergressor
stoppen wollen genau und dafür müssen
wir entsprechend natürlich auch für
Druck sorgen und deswegen ist die
Initiative von macron nach China zu
fahren und mit zu reden und mich zu
bewegen Druck auf Russland
heute unbedingt mein Handy darüber
liegen sie noch mal nach lasking bei
Fragen der SPD-Chef hat ja sehr explizit
Olaf Scholz noch nicht so doch Olaf
Scholz eigentlich auch schon gesagt dass
wir neue sicher eine neue
Sicherheitslage haben die nicht mehr mit
Russland in Europa funktioniert sondern
nur noch eine Sicherheit vor oder gegen
Russland sein kann würden sie ihm
zustimmen oder würden Sie sagen das ist
falsch und wir müssen in diesen in
Anführungsstrichen alten Kategorien
denken das Russland einfach als Land
immer da sein wird und dass wir also mit
Russland auch unsere Sicherheit
definieren sollten ich glaube das ist
die große Lehre damals vielleicht ein
bisschen Generationenkonflikt die die
nach 1990 politisch sozialisiert wurden
die entsteht das nicht in den Knochen
werden diese dauernden nuklear
Kriegsgefahr die davor eben doch ganze
Generationen geprägt hat auch mich sehr
stark geprägt hat und ich glaube wir
müssen schon irgendwann zu der
Erkenntnis kommen und das muss man
natürlich erstmal vorbereiten das dauert
das ist mir klar dass das nicht morgen
kommen kann es kann keine Sicherheit
gegen eine nuklear macht allein
organisiert werden sondern Sicherheit
das ist nun mal eine der wesentlichen
Erkenntnisse wir können ja froh sein
dass es nicht zum nuklear Krieg bislang
eskaliert ist eine der großen
Erkenntnisse ist aus diesen Jahrzehnten
des Kalten Krieges wir müssen
Sicherheitsinteressen aller Akteure
aller unabhängig davon welchen Status
sie haben ernst nehmen und Strukturen
schaffen in denen es Kriege schon
deswegen nicht mehr gibt weil der
jeweilige Adresse dabei nur verlieren
kann deswegen bin ich auch sehr kritisch
gegenüber der Vorstellung wir ordnen
jetzt in Welthandel neu und Handeln und
verhandeln treiben handeln nur noch mit
Staaten die unsere Vorstellung von
Demokratie und Menschenrechte teilen
weil dieser Rückgang der Interdependenz
nicht nur zu lassen das globalen Südens
ginge sondern diese Spaltung und die
gefahren wird wieder erhöht darüber
werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
schaffen zu diskutieren aber wir merken
uns diesen Gedanken und kehren noch mal
zurück was wir ansonsten ja den Medien
auch täglich entnehmen nämlich diesen
Kampf um die Waffen wir haben Graf
Lamsdorf ich wollte sie dann nach
unbedingt noch Fragen Waffen in diesem
winterwaffen in diesem Krieg die
Aufforderungen nehmen nicht ab dass die
Ukraine unterstützen müssen und das
Europa das Deutschland hat Personen
haben sie zu wenig unterstützt und wir
jetzt endlich Leos liefern sollen und
mit diesen Panzern sich dann
entscheidend etwas an der Situation
ändern würde ich zeig's noch mal ganz
kurz damit wir uns alle auch noch auf
diesen letzten Stand bringen
Deutschland hat der Ukraine bisher 30
gepaart Panzer geliefert ihr Einsatz ein
voller Erfolg
am Montag soll ein Gepard einen
Marschflugkörper abgeschossen haben
gestern habe ich dieses Video an meine
deutsche Kollegin geschickt mit Dank für
den Schutz des Luftraums
gleichzeitig drängt die Ukraine
Deutschland mehr Waffen zu liefern ganz
oben auf der Liste Leopard Panzer und
Patrick Luftabwehrsysteme
diese Forderungen war lange das
Top-Thema dass die Leos unbedingt
geliefert werden sollen und wir haben
gelesen Graf Lambsdorff dass die
Amerikaner seit Oktober den Deutschen
schon erlauben dass sie das tun können
können Sie uns helfen mit dem was Sie
darüber wissen warum tun wir es nicht
warum ermutigen uns die Amerikaner sogar
diese Kampfpanzer zu liefern weil sie
ihre Abrams nicht schicken wollen oder
welche anderen Gründe gibt
also ich mache jetzt was was sie hassen
werden Frau Illner ich werde zunächst
einmal noch ganz kurz auf das eingehen
was denn die darüber liegen gerade
gesagt hat dass man nämlich Sicherheit
nicht gegen einen nuklear mache ja genau
loswerden das ist schon 1949 bis 1989
exakt das gewesen was wir getan haben
wir haben in den beiden großen
nuklearbrücken Sicherheit gegeneinander
organisiert dieses gegeneinander war ein
gemanagtes gegeneinander aber das war
keineswegs eine kooperative Beziehung im
Kalten Krieg also insofern ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir zu einer
sicherheitsordnung mit Russland
wiederkommen können ich habe das ja eben
gesagt Russland muss entscheiden wo es
hin will in Bezug auf Europa aber das
ist nicht möglich sei gegen Russland
Sicherheit für Europa zu organisieren
das ist objektiv falsch das haben wir
jetzt 40 Jahre lang gesehen jetzt komme
ich zu Ihrer Frage wir haben
Abrüstungsverträge in den 70er Jahren
geschlossen
wir haben abrüstungs-
mit einem wirklich üblen System was
diese und zweifellos war geschlossen wir
haben die Parität anerkannt explizit die
Parität damit es nicht zu einer
Eskalation von Konflikten kommt
natürlich können wir jetzt Wortklauberei
betreiben natürlich ist das auch
Sicherheit gegen jemand organisieren
aber eben unter Anerkennung
wechselseitig von Sicherheitsinteressen
anders geht's nicht wenn wir das
Vergessen dann macht man muss ich mir
wirklich Sorgen machen über fast die
Zukunft also wir wollen jetzt nicht zu
viel Semantik machen aber es ist
Management eines Gegeneinanders ist
natürlich auch die hohe Konzept
Diplomatie und die große Ära der wird
Abrüstung kam am Ende der 80er Anfang
der 90er Jahre
richtig massiv
aber lassen Sie mich mal zu den Systemen
kommen Frau die sie gerade eingegangen
sind also insofern war es eine gute
Intervention
ich weiß ja
durchaus nützlich die Leos Spaß und
warum nicht
also es gibt keinen einziges westliches
Land das Kampfpanzer liefert und wir
haben in Deutschland in der Diskussion
auch in meiner Partei ja viele Stimmen
die sagen das sollten wir tun ich habe
der große Sympathie für ich würde
allerdings mich einer Idee anschließen
wollen die der Vorsitzende des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses hatte Michael
Roth von der SPD der sagte wenn wir das
wirklich machen wollen also mit
Kampfpanzern dann sollten wir das auf
jeden Fall im Verbund des Bündnisses
oder zumindest der Europäerinnen und
Europäer tun ich halte das deswegen für
richtig weil wir in Bündnis zwei
Grundsätze haben der eine Grundsatz ist
die Lastenteilung also wir teilen uns
die Kosten und der andere ganz wichtige
Grundsatz ist die risiko-teilung wir
teilen uns die Risiken und das haben wir
ja bei den Waffenlieferungen die wir
bisher machen auch genauso gehandhabt
wir liefern alle Luftabwehr wir liefern
alle Artillerie wir liefern alle
gepanzerte Truppentransporter da würde
ich beispielsweise sagen Fuchs da geht
auf jeden Fall noch was 100 oder 200
können wir auf jeden Fall abgeben nicht
einzusehen warum das nicht geschieht ich
würde sogar beim
Kampfpanzer Marder war dort bei so einem
Schützenpanzer Marder sagen das ginge
auch noch weil die risk exposure die
risikoexposition wäre mein Auto noch
Antrag war beim Leopard bin ich wie
gesagt der Meinung wenn man es im
Verbund macht dann ist es eine Sache mit
der die Ukraine in die Lage versetzt
werden könnte das besetzte Territorium
von russischen Soldaten zu befreien das
könnte eine Hilfe sein aber ich würde es
nicht immer nationalen Alleingang machen
wollen ich glaube das wäre auch für
Deutschland und wir haben es eben gehört
das wäre für Deutschland eine zu hohe
Risiko
expositionelle Eingang mich interessiert
natürlich jetzt auch die Meinung von
ihnen allen Marina weißband ähm Kollege
haben wir zitiert die Ukraine bitte
darum seit vielen Tagen und Wochen das
auch Kampfpanzer geliefert werden und
nicht nur Schützenpanzerwagen denken
auch Sie dass es damit noch mal eine
also wie soll man das formulieren das
ist dann mit schneller einen Sieg geben
könnte
also was die politischen und
militärischen Rahmendaten betrifft dazu
haben die meisten Menschen an diesem
Tisch klügerisch zu sagen als ich ich
kann nur eines sagen
die Ukrainer wissen was Sie brauchen und
wenn Sie darum bitten haben Sie gute
Gründe wir haben sehr lange gezögert das
zu liefern was wir jetzt geliefert haben
und wir sehen wie welchen Einfluss das
jetzt schon hat dieser Krieg hätte im
Sommer vorbei sein können das was wir
jetzt erleben hätte nicht sein müssen
wenn wir jetzt weiter zögern wenn wir
jetzt weiter sagen keiner Alleingänge
und nicht das und nicht dies obwohl wir
helfen können dann machen wir uns
mitschuldig an allem was weiter passiert
das ist einfach so
dieser Krieg hätte im Sommer zu Ende
sein können der Masala weiß ich nicht
also wage ich jetzt erstmal so zu
bezweifeln aber was natürlich richtig
ist er wäre einem anderen Punkt als er
jetzt ist weil in dem Moment in dem die
Ukraine mit dem gegen offensiven
angefangen hat da geht's um
Schnelligkeit Feuerkraft und Panzerung
und das sind halt Sachen die bietet
jetzt aus einer deutschen Perspektive
der Mörder der Fuchs nicht so sehr die
bietet der Leopard das ist wichtig für
Rückeroberungen von sozusagen von
russisch besetzen Gebieten das wird
heute auch noch gebraucht also wir haben
sozusagen jetzt diese Kampfhandlungen
wieder im Osten im Süden weniger
momentan aber im Osten haben wir sie und
da fehlt ganz einfach das um Gebiet
zurückzuerobern was für den die
interessante Sache ist der Vorschlag von
Michael Roth ist ein guter man darf nur
nicht in die Falle laufen jetzt
sämtliche Leo Modelle zu liefern weil
das ist sozusagen ein logistischer Alb